[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal de tv 78 tout de suite les
titres de ce mercredi 19 décembre le
département et saint quentin en yvelines
ont signé hier une convention elles
fixent le cadre pour la rénovation
urbaine de huit quartiers de
l'agglomération
seize opérations et été identifiés comme
des constructions et des aménagements de
voirie le département va s'engager à
hauteur de 15 millions d'euros
des jeunes de plaisir et des environs en
irlande en octobre dernier ils ont
participé un trek de 150 kilomètres à
pied dans la région du connemara depuis
2015 la mission locale qu organise cette
action pour aider ces demandeurs
d'emploi à franchir un cap dans leur
parcours professionnel retour
d'expérience en plateau
et puis le palais des sports de plaisir
accueillait cette semaine un match de
gala des handballeurs moins de 18 ans du
sky vgp défier les féminines du paris 92
une rencontre inédite devant plus de 600
spectateurs
nous parlerons également du dernier run
avant les fêtes dans les magasins des
yvelines exemple au centre commercial la
ouananiche chaîne paris aux
clayes-sous-bois dont nous recevrons
saha directrice avant de développer ces
titres une journaliste de france 3
agressé hier ali mais elle aurait été
frappée à la tente alors qu'elles
tournaient des images à un rond-point
occupés par des gilets jaunes
précisons qu'au moment où je vous parle
nous ignorons si l'auteur du coup
appartient à ce mouvement dès gilet
jaune ceux présents sur place lui ont en
tout cas porter secours l'individu a
pris la fuite
une plainte va être déposée par france 3
ile de france suite à cette agression et
une information dont nous vous parlions
hier le gilet jaune qui a été frappé
dans la nuit de lundi à mardi sur ce
même barrage de l'imep se trouvait
toujours ce soir entre la vie et la mort
sur les sept prochaines années les
yvelines prévoit d'investir 7 701
millions d'euros pour ces territoires en
politique de la ville hier la
collectivité et saint quentin en
yvelines ont signé une convention
concernant huit quartiers de
l'agglomération un plan en dames horse
pour pallier les retards pris par le
programme national de rénovation urbaine
patrick jacques de dixmude et mélanie
poquet
c'est une signature à 15 millions
d'euros cette convention entre le
département des yvelines et
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines porte sur la rénovation urbaine
c'est pas une commune aujourd'hui qui
peut faire face bien sûr à de tels
engagements
donc heureusement le département des
yvelines vient bien sûr nous nous
accompagner nous soutenir et puis
effectivement déclenché avec ses moyens
ces opérations de rénovation dont on a
terriblement besoin dans ces quartiers
là le département veut poursuivre ce que
l'état ne fait plus l'état à
l'initiative de jean louis borloo alors
ministre d'état ministre de la ville
s'était engagée dans le renouvellement
urbain petit à petit on voit que ce qui
a été fait se dégrade et l'impatience de
ceux pour qui rien n'est fait et le
risque c'est qu'on retombe dans cette
spirale vicieuse et négatives
restructuration de gymnase
réhabilitation des espaces publics
ces opérations ont été recensés pour
cette commune et huit quartiers dont
deux à trappes
nous ça nous permet d'intervenir sur des
opérations dès maintenant et ça permet
aussi aux bailleurs d'intervenir sur
quelques opérations avec des
subventionnements élevé puisque ça
atteint 70% du montant des travaux dans
un cadre de cinq millions d'euros pour
la ville de trappes ça concerne nous
surtout d'agrandissement d'écoles ou des
aménagements autour des cols parce que
c'est toujours la con con
travailler en priorité puis ça concerne
pergaud debussy et védrine ans il
concerne des lieux d'habitat elle la
rénovation urbaine sur saint quentin en
yvelines est évalué à plus de 37
millions d'euros
les projets doivent être lancés avant le
31 décembre 2019 nj - 6 avant noël les
français ont prévu de dépenser cette
année en moyenne 340 euros pour leurs
cadeaux elle les fêtes de fin d'année
période de rush forcément dans les
magasins qui s'accélère ces derniers
jours avec les derniers achats bonsoir
lydia dragon dans sa merci d'être avec
nous sur ce plateau vous êtes la
directrice de l'exploitation du centre
commercial wayne nacion paris aux
clayes-sous-bois 90 boutiques de grandes
marques dédiées à la haute lande c'est à
dire qu'il prend elle propose ses
boutiques des collections haut des
saisons précédentes avec une des marques
la période des fêtes c'est une période
capitale pour votre établissement
absolument on est une destination
cadeaux chacun vient pour pouvoir
trouver la liste ce qu'on est orienté
plutôt mode ou accessoires et
effectivement ça fait partie de la liste
des cadeaux parce que ça représente une
grande part du chiffre d'affaires
c'est qu'il semble c'est le troisième
mois de l'année et ce qui est une
organisation particulière on sait que
des centres commerciaux organise des
animations notamment au moment de noël
des promotions aussi spéciale à cette
période est ce que c'est le cas au
venetian paris oui tout à fait enfin
c'est le cas toute l'année en fait on a
six animations sur les grandes périodes
de vacances scolaires
et là en ce moment on a une patinoire
sur 100 mètres carrés un glacier
escalader et on a les traditionnels père
noël qui est fait un petit détour pour
venir à one nation et des chorales du
gospel pour pouvoir effectivement avoir
un petit clerc de sectes donc le centre
commercial qui s'est mis en mode noël
est ce qu il ya une amplitude aussi
horaires d'ouverture plus élargie
peut-être non nous on est déjà ouvert
7/7 donc on est déjà au maximum mais il
convient notamment les 24 et 31 décembre
tout à fait c'est à dire qu'on pourra
venir les raids dernier voilà les
retardataires pourront venir faire leurs
derniers achats de noël
c'est absolument exquis une vision souci
renforcer en ces périodes sur la
sécurité au centre commercial
oui on fait attention effectivement on a
dit densifier les effectifs comme les
effectifs de vente d'ailleurs mai
il n'y a rien à signaler
d'extraordinaire et et à quoi ressemble
ces derniers jours la cette dernière
semaine avant noël
il ya beaucoup de clients qui viennent
qui s'affairent dans les boutiques et un
peu de stress dans la dernière ligne
droite donc à les clients toujours un
peu peur de ne pas trouver leur cadeau
et au final il reporte plein de ça
qu'ils sont heureux s'ils ont fait des
bonnes affaires dont on est remisé en ce
moment alors qu'en ce moment personne ne
propose des remises donc ils font bien
évidemment des affaires pas de baisse de
la fréquentation constatée en
conséquence du mouvement des gilet jaune
on sait que ça a pu impacter d'autres
centres commerciaux en france saf a été
constatée sur la clientèle française non
la clientèle touristique est un petit
peu impacté alors c'est une année
particulière pour one nation à paris
puisque vous fêté cette année vos cinq
ans c'est un anniversaire qui a été
célébrée fin novembre il y avait
beaucoup d'animation autour de l'espace
c'est un moment on imagine particulier
pour le centre commercial oui cinq ans
déjà j'ai envie de dire mais on a fêté
cet anniversaire autour de l'espace où
on a décidé que cinq ans c'était notre
année lumière
et on a fait une grande période de
remise commerciale supplémentaire où on
a accueilli beaucoup de personnes et on
a fait un mois de novembre en finit avec
un chiffre d'affaires à plus 20 donc
c'est quand même une très très belle
opération mais ce sera ma dernière
question est-ce qu'en cinq ans wang chen
paris a su trouver sa clientèle
oui elle a su trouver sa clientèle sur
son bassin local c'est à dire qu'on a
aujourd'hui une notoriété sur le 78e
aussi sur le 92 et sur l'a75 et on
touche de plus en plus loin cirque on a
accueilli deux nouvelles jolies petites
marques de mode qui font venir des gens
de rouen d'evreux de dreux donc on
élargit un peu naze zone est ce qu'on
peut s'attendre à des nouveautés pour
2010 9 points et on suivra tout ça plus
d'informations à retrouver sur le site
internet de oignies shon paris merci à
lydia de rebond d'avoir été avec nous et
je rappelle que vous êtes la directrice
de l'exploitation de ce centre
commercial qui est située aux
clayes-sous-bois et en vue de ces fêtes
de fin d'année on continue de vous
partager des idées de cadeaux made in
yvelines partons ce soir du côté de
versailles pour découvrir des créations
d'une artisanes nathalie de la ville et
on propose des pièces uniques sac ou
encore pochette est découverte avec
michael et demi d'euros et mélanie poké
et si au pied du sapin le père noël
déposer des sacs en tissu ou des
pochettes des produits artisanaux en
série très limitée
la créatrice nathalie de la ville et on
multiplie les marchés de noël les
marchés de noël me permettent de
rencontrer mes clientes d'aller
face
au public d'avoir les remontées
d'informations et puis des réactions de
d'éventuels clients sur les produits
donc c'est à la fois moteur et seat est
satisfaisant bienvenue dans mon atelier
donc c'est le sous sol de ma maison un
atelier versailles est lancée en 2013
nathalie de la ville et on y crée exposé
sur rendez vous depuis cinq ans auprès
de 4000 pièces ont vu le jour
nathalie utilise sa première aiguille à
l'âge de 8 ans tout est fait main tout
est fait chaque pièce sort de l'atelier
sortie si je suis la seule à coudre donc
toutes les pochettes c'est moi qui les
ai faites du motif au tissu la
versaillaise pense chaque détail un sac
lui demande cinq heures de travail
elle crée également pochette et
accessoires de mode pour les bijoux
c'est une affaire de famille
les bijoux se sont développés parce que
ma fille aînée s'est prise d'affection
pour les perles et s'est mise à plein
d'idées donc elle s'est mise à
développer cette activité là aussi est
comment dire à partir de janvier elle va
passer autant entrepreneurs de façon à
pouvoir devenir mon fournisseur
nathalie de la ville et on propose ses
produits essentiellement aux ventes
privées par les réseaux sociaux et le
bouche à oreille
ses créations sont envoyés dans toute la
france et à l'étranger
je peux m'adapter aux besoins de la
cliente c'est à dire que si elle vingt
cinq plus grands plus petit des ans plus
grande
quelque chose qui soit plutôt porté
épaule cette année j'ai fait surtout des
portes épaules pour pour l'hiver parce
que on m'avait dit voilà on aimerait
bien pouvoir le mettre sur nos manteaux
territoire à la fois regarder quelques
produits sont aussi disponibles dans une
boutique à versailles nathalie il
propose une cinquantaine de créations
c'est très important d'être en boutique
en plus des marchés
comment dire qu'ils sont relativement
saisonniers parce que les évènements
lieu en général en fin d'année ou au
moment de mars avril
mais je ça me permet d'avoir la
possibilité de rencontrer aussi des gens
ailleurs que chez moi je peux pas ouvrir
l'atelier non plus à tout le monde ça me
permet de m'inscrire dans
dans un univers puisque françois ce
travail par par univers tout et on n'a
pas de death passe particulièrement
dédié on est un peu partout dans la
boutique des créations dans une large
palette de couleurs pour se faire
plaisir hein ça coûte entre 15 et 70
euros pour les boucles d'oreilles
compter de 12 à 45 euros
il ya des jeunes de plaisir et des
environs en trek en irlande en octobre
dernier par exemple 12 jeunes ont
parcouru à pied 150 km en six jours dans
la région du connemara c'est une action
pour aider ces personnes en recherche
d'emploi ou qui s'interrogent tout
simplement sur leur avenir les aider à
se fixer un cap alors autour de la table
pour en parler trois participants alors
ils ont pas forcément participé aux
derniers trek mais en tout cas à cette
action du coaching trek vadim pelletier
bonsoir c'est s'asseoir il ya également
coumba almont soir et christophe caye
bonsoir ça merci d'être avec nous et
vous êtes accompagné de samuel van
houtte on prononce van houtte c'est bien
tout est très bien mais vous êtes-vous
bénévole dans l'association nouvelles
perspectives qui copilote cette action
alors la mission locale de plaisir qui
est devenu aujourd'hui mission locale de
50 en une avec mon partenariat avec la
ville de plaisir l'association nouvelles
perspectives emmène ses jeunes pour ce
genre d'actions et ça ça se fait depuis
2015 comment et comment est né ce projet
samuel alors c'est dans le cadre du
contrat de ville
donc dès 2015
on avait identifié le fait que pour un
certain nombre de jeunes inscrits à la
mission locale
c'était pas forcément évident d'aller au
bout des démarches qui était accomplie
qui avait beaucoup d'envié beaucoup de
deux dynamiques mais souvent il y avait
le petit truc qui fait qu'on va pas au
bout de quelque chose donc on s'est dit
qu'il fallait absolument qu'on développe
une action terrain
à travers laquelle les jeunes seront
confrontés à cette notion d'effort et a
trouvé les ressources pour aller au delà
de l'envy d'abandon alors cette action
elle se fait à pied il ya une vingtaine
de kilomètres parcourus par jour
l'objectif bien sûr s'est terminé ce
parcours pourquoi le faire à pied c'est
de rajouter une petite difficulté à ce
projet ce qui est intéressant avec la
marche c'est que déjà la marque nous
apprend énormément de choses sur sur soi
même et puis la marche est accessible à
tous ou quasi à tous et malgré tout
quand on est amené à faire 25 à 30 km
par jour et tous les jours au bout des
premiers kilomètres parfois il ya
évidemment de la vie le pardon l'envi
d'abandonner lee qui prend le pas et ce
que l'on fait avec l'association
nouvelles perspectives c'est d'aider et
d'accompagner au mieux les différents
participants pour aller au delà de ça et
donc c'est bien sûr la force mentale que
l'on travaille et c'est juste magique
parce que petit à petit avec eux la
magie des mots la magie départ on avance
on progresse et on réalise quelque chose
ensemble juste d'extraordinaire on va
faire un petit tour de table combat qui
étiez vous avant cette aventure allons
presser sous vous n'avez pas participé
au dernier coaching trek mais à un autre
coaching trek en irlande dans la région
du bea race et ça franchement mort au
début je me connaissaient pas avant trek
je ne connaissais pas même quand on
proposait le tertre et je voulais pas y
aller
au fur et à mesure des préparatifs
jusqu'au des voeux jusqu'au bout et ont
séduit franchement pourquoi pas parce
que j'étais jeune je me cherchais donc
je savais pas qui j'étais vraiment et
pendant lautrec
en fait on se rend pas compte mais le
fait de marcher au début et peut-être
c'est dur mais après on oublie la
douleur tellement tu penses à ton avenir
à quoi tu sers dans la vie vraiment
c'est quoi le but pour toi pourtant
c'est quoi réussir
donc franchement a pris les traits je me
suis dit voilà là j'ai trouvé ce que je
vais faire je marchais 30 km
j'ai prouvé qui j'étais je veux prendre
mes propres des six décisions sans
compter sur mes parents les limbes
franchement je sais de dix jours
d'aujourd'hui des sèche-cheveux et j'ai
envie
projet connaissez votre but lors du
second but il est clair et net
parce que au fur et à mesure du trait je
me suis rendu compte que j'étais fait
pour aider les personnes
donc c'est mon but là je suis en service
et vicky à pôle emploi mais en même
temps je travaille à bord working pour
préparer mon projet de devenir la
première et je vais y aller quand on l'a
compris à une transformation totale
avant et après lui ce trek en face de
vous ma dîme qui a aussi participé à ce
trek dans la région du dubé arts à paris
vous étiez qui avant ma dîme avant bas
je me cherchais aussi je n'avais pas
trop ce que je voulais faire dans la vie
et justement c'était une occasion pour
moi de me découvrir de savoir qui je
suis et qu'est ce que je veux surtout et
du coup maintenant je sais ce que je
veux et je fais un service civique dans
une école primaire et à côté de ça
j'étudie le montage et j'aimerais bien
entraîner une école de montage pour
pouvoir faire de la vidéo donc de
nouvelles aventures nouvelles
perspectives christophe vous le c'était
le dernier trait que vous avez participé
à ce trek en octobre dans la région du
connemara
c'est ça tout à faire et donc vous vous
étiez qui la rend christophe mêmes
questions la même question
en fait j'étais aussi un peu perdu je
venais d'arrêter un secteur d'activité
dans le bâtiment et je savais pas du
tout vers quoi m'orienter est en fait
avant ce truc là je faisais des projets
mais j'allais pas au bout parce que je
savais pas pourquoi je le faisais
d'accord skis à ce qui a pu changer avec
le trek vu que on a le temps de
réfléchir et de se poser les bonnes
questions
samuel je me retourne vers vous pendant
ce périple et les jeunes porte un sac un
sac lourd c'est vous le confirmer
c'était l'été lourd ce sac
pourquoi qu'est ce que ça signifie en ce
sens leurs affaires et en fait on
travaille beaucoup sur sur les symboles
la route représente le le projet de vie
où la vie du projet la météo c'est aussi
les aléas de la vie donc il faut les
intégrer comme ça parfois on a le dos
qui nous fall part dans le vent qui nous
pousse dans le dos parfois on l'a de
face le sac à dos c'est aussi tout le
potentiel qu'on peut avoir une chaque
jeune peut avoir et c'est aussi parfois
l'histoire le passé les choses que l'on
est amené à porter et quoi qu'il arrive
il faut aller au bout de l'aventuré il
faut vivre cette expérience au bout
l'abandon n'est pas possible et même
s'il ya des moments de doute des moments
peut-être d'énervement de fatigue
physique des moments on a mal
physiquement ça arrive des fois les yeux
au delà de ça et tout là toute la force
du projet c'est d'aller au delà de ces
difficultés qu'on peut rencontrer et il
ya une force
il ya une dynamique collective qui
chacun à aller au bout et et chacun
aussi alimentent cette force collective
donc c'est il ya comme une alchimie qui
se crée une autour de ce projet qui est
qui est juste magique
on a vu des images d'un film d'ailleurs
sur le coaching trek dans la région
d'hubert ras le film se nomme l'homme
prévoit dieu rit je vous invite à le
regarder un film très intéressant on
voit que la clé de la réussite aussi
c'est que vous aviez un groupe soudé
alors christophe peut-être que ce sera
vous me direz vous allez me dire la même
chose dans un instant mon a vu dans le
film va dire que vous étiez un groupe
soudé pendant comment ce trek c'est ça
aider les autres c'est la base de tout
en fait c'est apprendre à se trouver soi
c'est aussi trouver les autres c c'est
en fait il n'ya même pas je sais plus
quoi dire bonsoir c'est pas grave mais
oui beaucoup moins on l'a vu des moments
vraiment de solidarité où on n'avait pas
présent on a les bonnes histoires pour
aller de l'avant
certains laventure pour pour se
découvrir mais le fait d'être en groupe
de voir les caractères de chacun les
forces de la force mentale chacun sent
le fait avancer le fait de dire que s'il
ya une personne qui abandonne c'est pas
un échec personnel c'est un échec pour
tout le groupe
donc on était obligé de soutenir parce
qu'on savait où il ya des moments plus
les quais les autres et que peut-être et
les autres se débrouillent mieux que les
autres dans fallait qu'on se soutienne
et aller jusqu'au bout c'était dans le
connemara pardon christophe paris s'il y
avait de la solidarité entre vous alors
complètement ouais on était tous
solidaires entre nous malgré les aléas
des préparations qu'on fait qu'on le
groupe a été finalisée vraiment presque
au dernier moment et malgré tout il ya
quelque chose qui s'est passé et tout le
monde était soudé tout le monde
s'entraidait tu es quelqu'un était dans
la douleur quelqu'un venu le réconforter
et ça nous a permis de réaliser cet
exploit qui est de base individuelle à
le transformer en exploit de groupe en
fait et d'ailleurs suite à ces traits
coup une attestation pardon de
participation vous a été remis c'était
au cours d'une soirée le 5 décembre
dernier au théâtre robert manuel de
plaisir qui a débuté avec la projection
de deux films revenant sur vos aventures
dans la salle notamment la sous préfète
des yvelines en charge de la politique
de la ville et joséphine coleman ce
berger maire de plaisir et lui vous a
trouvé totalement transformé je vous
propose de l'écouter on les connaît on
les connaissait avant les connaissez on
les connaît après et sont plus du tout
les mêmes d'abord ils ont un sens du
collectif
un sens de l'amitié qui c'est sûr
développer c'est un projet et c'est une
une aventure qu'ils n'oublieront jamais
c'est une vraie démarche humaine a une
vraie démarche qui a lié à la fois
l'effort bien sûr et puis la confiance
en soi surtout parce qu'ils se rendent
compte que bien ils sont capables de
faire quelque chose de a à z et surtout
qui n'est pas facile dont il le
reproduire reproduisent ensuite et bien
au niveau de leur emploi de la recherche
et puis des études c c'est
extraordinaire comme projet samuel pour
refermer cet entretien on l'a entendu au
travers de ces témoignages
on les sent totalement transformé après
votre histoire mais c'est vraiment le
but en ils peuvent trouver du coup en
eux ils le savent tout
toute leur force qui va être exploité
pour que chacun puisse se réaliser dans
le projet d'origine projet professionnel
est ce que c'est ça qui compte
moi je voudrais simplement souligné que
depuis qu'on développe cette action avec
la ville de plaisir et skywest 25 la
mission locale territoire
à peu près de 70 jeunes qui ont
bénéficié de cette action ils ont tous
été orientés vers cette action pour des
raisons de difficulté d'avancer dans
leur projet et ses 70 jeunes sont tous
en situation
trois mois à l'issue du très tôt qu'il
ya bien une vraie révolution îlots de
terre qui ce fait discret un moment
référence à partir duquel les jeunes
peuvent aller vers des nouvelles places
et puis ça marche merci beaucoup
samuel merci christophe coumba et merci
à vadim d'être passé sur ce plateau des
prochains rendez vous à venir peut
peut-être en tout cas vous pouvez
retrouver l'actualité de l'association
nouvelle perspective sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
on resta plaisir pour parler handball un
match d'entraînement entre les jeunes
jusqu'à iv gt les féminines du paris 92
était organisée en début de semaine dans
un palais des sports bien garni pour
l'occasion un retour avec mika et demi
d'euros un match de gala au palais des
sports de plaisir niveau de 18 ans du
sky vgp recevait pour la première fois
les féminines du paris 92 plus de 600
supporters avaient pris place en
tribunes pour cette rencontre inédite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mon ambiance parce qu'on trouvait tous
ensemble c'est la fête d'un club aussi à
un local
le spectacle était également rendez vous
sur le terrain la mi temps les jeunes
handballeurs mendy 7 à 13 après un
premier acte plein d'intensité un bon
match on a des bonnes choses en face ça
joue bien techniquement elles sont au
dessus de nous mais c'est vrai que
physiquement on n'est pas mal du coup on
arrive à rattraper l'écart en deuxième
période l'écart se creuse entre les
joueurs locaux survoltés dans leur salle
et le pari 92 diminuée par l'absence de
onze joueuses
score final de cette rencontre amicale
34 à 28
ils sont plus grands plus costaud plus
lourd plus rapide plus vive
ils sont 60 sur le banc longueur on
n'avait aucune chance à rendre le match
mais c'est un match de travail
c'est intéressant ce qu'on arrache
montre plus joué sur la trajectoire de
balle après
on a pas que ton dès qu'on a beaucoup de
puissance révélations n'en fait un bon
match de la globalité et je trouve ça
super intéressant en plan plan de magna
et le souhait de l'entraîneur du sky vgp
pourrait être exaucé d'autres rencontres
entre les féminines du paris 92 des
jeunes illinois pourraient être
programmées dans le futur accord est les
vacances de noël approchent et du en
cours a ouvert aujourd'hui sa première
patinoire éphémère installé à
l'intérieur du pavillon waldeck rousseau
cet équipement synthétique est proposée
jusqu'au 31 décembre
ouvert à tous au tarif de 4 euros vous
pourrez patiné pendant 30 minutes le
matériel est fourni sur place il faut
seulement être munis de gants propos
recueillis par nicolas landry
c'est super parce que regarder des
dessins animés avec les filles qui se
passait dans des patinoires et emmenés
et pourquoi ne pas aller faire un tour
dans les cinémas pendant ses congés
direction le ciné 7 à elancourt pour
notre visite du mercredi dans les salles
obscures saint-quentinoise c'est au
micro de patrick jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
alors vacances de noël approchant oblige
une grosse programmation cette semaine
aussi les sets avec deux sorties
nationales
le blockbuster de chez warner aquaman en
2d 3d vfb au donc sur nos écrans cette
semaine est aussi le dernier disney leur
tour de mary poppins la suite attendue
les aventures de mary poppins qui pleins
d'autres films de qualité
pupilles de génériques reprenons cette
semaine bohemian rhapsody pour les fans
de queen et aussi les autres qui
connaissent pas la vie de freddie
mercury toujours super vfv aux robins
des bois le grand bain pour ceux qui
n'ont pas vu les disney de noël tous les
ans on fait une petite opération passe
des vieux disney donc là c'est cette
semaine c'est cendrillon et monstres et
compagnie astérix toujours et secrets de
l'appelation magique pour les familles
l'autriche aussi et ainsi défilent ou
pour les tout petits
mimi elisa les lumières de noël dimanche
matin à 10h30 et bonne fête à tout le
monde pour cette fin d'année
[Musique]
enfin ce reportage que nous devions vous
proposait hier depuis plus de 25 ans les
archers de guyancourt organisent leur
tournoi annuel il est qualificatif pour
les championnats de france
un bon entraînement qui attire des
pointures de la discipline marylène
iapichino et nicolas landry 26 cible
aligné au sein du gymnase maurice baquet
comme chaque année avant les fêtes de
noël les archers de willencourt organisé
ce week end un grand tournoi ont fini
entre guillemets la phase de préparation
pour les bons à tête qui eux vont
pouvoir s'aligner derrière sur les
championnats départementaux régionaux ou
alors le championnat de france et a lieu
deuxième quinzaine de février
trois départs différents surtout le
week-end avant les finales du dimanche
après-midi 235 archers sont venus
disputer leurs flèches un tournoi ouvert
à tous on accueille les gens qui sont 10
sport on les classe avec mais ils ont
aussi une licence supplémentaire une
licence handisport qui leur permet
d'être comptabilisés dans le classement
national ans d'histoire
tous les participants même objectif
toucher la cible
chacun son arc et chacun sa technique
pour touché dans le mille
je chante en fait pour essayer de
vraiment de rester bien concentré de
enlevez la tête de tenir droite etc
j'essaie essentiellement de faire le
vide est justement de penser que à la
cible et que tu aux gestes à réaliser
prochain rendez vous pour les archers de
guyancourt l'accueil du championnat
régional adultes au mois de février
c'est la fin de ce journal à suivre dans
un instant nouveau numéro du 7-8 débat
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]